i remember while we were filming jackass
forever and you were just getting all
this insane footage left and right and
i'm thinking oh my god dude like
danger's kind of gone under the radar
like in life you know and now like
you're going to be like so much more
recognizable in the streets has that
happened
it it has i mean it's kind of always
been there and you know like even with
like the the terror taxi you know like
this terror taxi bit like those kinds of
things people always know kind of who i
am and whatever but i don't i don't do a
lot of things like
putting me out into the public a lot
like i'm at home and doing my thing and
working on my life and touring with
bands shooting photos and when i'm out
people are like especially now people
are like [ __ ] we love you dude and it's
it's really cool
um
you know i i think there's obviously
strike by the irons hot opportunity when
we put out a new film or a new movie or
something but
i i have a one-year-old and i'm way more
stoked on what i'm doing right now than
anything i don't regret or wish i was
doing anything else i'm raising a rad
little baby and we have a nice little
family and i'll get back to it i really
feel that you're like you know of the
jackass guys like arguably the most
well-adjusted like the most like real
world like you know you don't really
identify as as like a celebrity guy
you're uh your livelihood comes from
real estate you've taken all of your
money and like wisely invested it and
properties and you manage all these
properties and stuff yeah um i mean
it's like any like
entertainer athlete or anything where
you make
some money
and people know who you are and when you
know it's awesome it's awesome but
eventually
nothing lasts forever and you really got
to just take that opportunity to do the
best you can with it for your future
because life is long even though we're
short dude life is [ __ ] long again
it's like yeah i'm rule right now
but two or three years from now and
you're not ruling and no one's paying
you anything what is what do you have
left and you just got to be thinking
about like you know goals in life where
you want to be five ten years from now
and actually visualize it like don't
just stumble around and be like whatever
happens to me
no make things happen like you gotta
work hard too like you work your ass off
but you're doing it because you you
enjoy doing this i mean i love it and
yeah i think you just uh
shared the best life advice you you have
to have a goal if you're going to
accomplish a goal yeah if you don't if
you don't set a you know a goal for
yourself then you're never going to do
anything yeah and goals do change and
you can allow your goals to change and
don't say that you you didn't succeed
because you didn't reach the goal that
you had just
be realistic like you know somebody
could say i want to
blo you know i want a ferrari and then
you get a toyota but you know your goal
then is now you've got a toyota and you
should be happy with it right so
so okay so how many real estate
properties are you said nine no uh
i just acquired two more uh in the last
three months so i've seven
seven sold one bought two and uh and and
most of these are on mortgage yeah uh a
couple are paid off okay but
uh most of them are on mortgage
especially the last three years
even if they weren't on mortgage i would
i went and got loans for them because
money was so cheap you know two and a
half percent or three percent rate so
um everything's locked down 30-year
fixed we'll see what happens you know
the the markets
probably like it did in oh eight go down
but if you're not selling then what's it
worth it's not worth less than it was
before right so you just hold on
long-term long game is 30-year plan you
know i've got a plan for each every
single one of them like how to sell them
when to sell them
you know depending on how i'm doing in
this business and whatnot like when
you're crushing it in hollywood and
you're making money you don't want to
sell your real estate because then you
you have to pay more in taxes right than
you already you already do so generally
the rule with real estate is just never
sell yeah right ultimately put it in the
trust give to the family peace
what was your situation in 2008 when uh
in 2008 i had five
properties
and that was just that was what you did
with your money from jackass one and two
damn yeah that's great when did three
come out no that was ten so yeah
so
from one and two uh i i uh
had five properties um i'd you know you
can buy one as and and you can leverage
off of that if you have good rent credit
and whatever else and uh but then the
market tanked and everyone was like
freaking out like people were like
offing themselves and and it was a very
stressful time but scott [ __ ] got his
ass kicked you sold
i pulled out the the down payment on a
credit card and then bought it in 06 and
then a week later it dropped like 60
grand
i just let it go after three years yeah
i mean at a certain point scott for the
first how many years we worked together
was like battling his way out of debt
through from years
everything from like what so many people
were i mean that's the thing is like if
it happens again there's going to be
another so many people and
earlier i i don't think it'll be
gnarlier uh i think it's it's gonna be
different i think everything affects
everything so like if you have like if
oil prices go up then food prices go up
then everything goes up and inflation
hits because we give away a bunch of
free money and don't
like and then now people are used to not
working to and not doing anything and
getting this money and then the money's
disappearing but they're like i'm still
don't want to go back to work like
and uh inflation's going up so i think
everything that you're describing
indicates that it's going to be gnarlier
when the [ __ ] hits the fan this well
it's a worldwide phenomenon on this one
the one before was based on bad credit
which was given to people that didn't
have
the right yeah it was like stated income
loans made it so that people could just
buy a house i bought a house with a 520
credit score and stayed at income and
you just probably said yeah
the guys like the guys like you have any
credit lines and i was like no he's like
can you go to like men's warehouse and
buy some socks on credit and then like
get you a line i'm like yeah i did that
he's like cool got you alone yeah seven
percent interest only yeah jesus okay
you got any weed
he was like chewing in my ear on the
floor
yeah that was a different time yeah you
don't think it's going to be the same
thing like what do you think's going to
crash first if it hasn't already i think
i think that because interest rates
auto loans well hot over prices are up
higher than they've ever been in the
history of new cars new cars because of
the supply chain supply chain and
inflation like everything's more like
like uh contractors if you hired a
contractor that was 65 bucks an hour
three years ago he's 125 now
and the materials that they're using
like the wood and metal and everything
that's tripled
so that means that home prices go up
because it costs more right but but
we were up in uh in portland oregon on
seaside oregon uh yeah you were like
he doesn't
you were like
with your own bare hands like [ __ ]
you're like a contractor too yeah i do
most of my own construction on my own
properties with
with licensed contractors and stuff when
needed but for the most part like i i've
learned how to do most of my own
contracting and what you did with your
how your main house in portland was
unbelievable yeah i did landscaping
the deck
it's a lot of work and that's the thing
like like i always think back to when
people like from goonies remember chunk
and everyone's like sure what happened
to you entertainment he's an
entertainment lawyer he's killing it
more than he would have probably had he
stayed in the hollywood business in the
sense of acting and people think he died
you're like oh that guy died he had to
because he was killing it and then he
disappeared but you disappeared from
hollywood and the entertainment industry
doesn't mean you died you can have a
life and there's like
normal people like like doing real lives
that have been in movies before and
how many people
uh are you a landlord too
um i have a couple of vacation rental
houses so
those constantly are being uh that's not
so bad like i i think of landlord and
i'm like [ __ ] man i don't know
i would never be able to like yeah i
don't want somebody you couldn't do it
here's one thing i've always bought my
real estate on base the premises premise
of and that is do i would i want to live
here so if the market tanked i lost
everything if this was a place that i
had to live and could afford it would i
want to live here and if i say no then
why would i want to buy it you can buy
it to make money and some people
approach the real estate
game as just monopoly let's make money
money money but i do it in a different
way where i really have a connection to
oregon i'm from there fourth generation
like i love it so much i want to be able
to invest as much into the place i love
most and i've had opportunities to buy
other places and make money but i just
didn't because i didn't want to live
there if i had to so i just buy places
where if i need to live there or move
there or want to like own it for the
rest of my life or and pass it down to
my daughter or something i think it's
you know that's the way i buy stuff i do
it
ultimately in in the end
i don't want to lose money but i'm doing
it more for for multiple reasons there's
tax implications you know all these
things there's like there's so many
benef good benefits to owning real
estate um
it is tough because when you're doing
real estate in the moment like a
toilet's broken you got to fix it like
with the stock market when it goes down
you just don't look at it just ah you
just avoid it when it comes back up and
you're like yeah i'm winning and then
when you're losing but when a toilet
breaks you're you can't be like i'm just
gonna ignore it because then there's
[ __ ] flying all over the place and then
that causes your floors to rot and then
next thing you know your foundation's
broken and
so real estate
is a constant hands-on game right and
that takes a lot of time and it takes
away from the time that would be spent
doing
more entertaining and whatnot but i
think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not going to waste your time
because i'm proven dude new york times
best seller my first book's five-star
rated on amazon and i have no doubt this
one will be two so get the autographed
copy right now by pre-ordering it at
stevo.com
yeah dude